hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to spooky hello okay
I really hope there isn't any more
errors because there actually was an
error that dropped just a little bit ago
and some textures did not seem right it
is a bit darker that it once was
Bank okay so that's weird usually I
wouldn't hear lightning this far down
into the house unless something actually
horrible is happening which that might
be true this is as far as I know this is
the last hundred rooms in this house so
this might lead to something really
interesting or this might just end Torah
anticlimactic
what is this I was a little different Oh
research report more whales are being
shipped to the facility tomorrow one for
the healthy inspection two that are
already dead for autopsies more and more
beached whales keep appearing around
those Islands and I still can't find the
cause of it well okay what does that
have to do with anything that's
happening right here whoa okay then so
I'm in room 9 yep Brian room 9 tens
another big room okay broken broken oh
hey this the whale observation room
research before whale oh one five Diaz
died much sooner than I expected while I
was away on holiday I regret not being
there but I had estimated it would live
much longer the dean that did the
autopsy said nothing seemed to be wrong
with the lungs but the stomach had a
circular hole about two feet in diameter
all the way through to the outside of
the whale this pretty much confirms a
parasite is the cause of death whoa hey
how's it going there hi
are you dead or are you still alive
Shamu so did it was did an alien face
hug a whale
then burst out of its stomach is that
what happened here we might be talking
about that
that's might be what's happening here
okay that's so weird
that's so weird why does it have to be
so dark oh it's too dark to see yeah no
kidding I already know that okay so we
need to find some way to turn on the
lights to deal with all these wails damn
it okay it's also very quiet hello hi uh
strain small bite marks they appear from
another smaller mammal but the strangest
thing about them is their placements
they're in an even row inside the
whale's stomach about five feet from the
bottom of the stomach lining okay weird
weave oh oh one five a is still alive
but gets into fits of thrashing and
surfacing more often than natural I
think there may be a problem with its
lungs but I don't have any tools that
would allow me to check it without dying
I would have to allow it to die from
whatever is causing it to then do an
autopsy
okay that's sad for the whale this is a
little bizarre hello hi and then I
watched carelessly as the sea rose above
the sky casting waving shadows over the
world
I saw the silhouettes of both creatures
familiar and forgotten and suddenly I
found myself falling upwards towards an
ocean of darkness
okay I don't know what that's from but
it seems awfully romantic okay uh all
righty then so I need to find some way
to turn on the power before I can do
anything else okay or no broken and
locked so if I go this way maybe I won't
open I think the water is too high
damn it well then what am I supposed to
do I didn't find another door that I
could
oh wait yeah they're more whales are
being shipped to the facility tomorrow
one for a healthy inspection two that
are already dead
oh no I already read that wait did I
read that then where am I going now
boom broken this is the observational
right yeah okay so I got to find a way
to get some power to this could find a
way to get some light to the rest of the
facility then it's gotta be a way damn
it
okay so there's got to be a power room
around here somewhere I just got to find
it maybe I got a little turned round
okay that's the door I came in that's
locked up is the only doing the door
here maybe in one of these is a key or
something no damn it
so there's got to be something else in
here where else could I go and one of
these rooms has got to be like oh okay
is it a good sound or a bad sound okay
so I got a lantern good good good
so that means I'm gonna be able to do
what I need to I think I cool so this is
interesting
I forgot I still have this I can defend
myself
hey-ho all right so now I can go over to
the other place it was too dark to see
here oh uh I don't know what this is
gonna be how would I know how would I
know at all oh we get out okay there we
go okay
that was interesting so what benefit did
that do me was there like research
before for there's got to be some clue
with the numbers of the reports or
whatever
one okay oh wait oh oh ah wait okay for
number two five feet so five the second
number is five second number is five
extra 4 1 3 2 4 1 3 2 maybe that's it
for 1 3 2 I think that might be at 4 1 3
2 okay
4 1 3 2 that's the only other reason
that weird poem would be be there so 4 1
3 2 okay bang bang on bang on baby bang
on okay I got a key key to what though
the research facility is now in dire
need of more engineers with the whole
block that is flooded and some vital
staff are missing
they're probably drowned I'm willing to
bet okay
also why is this here why is this here
why is any of this here so all these
were broken
the only other lock door was on the
other side I think okay side here here
okay yes please
I hear a girl or an animal or something
singing to me pleading that I come
outside my locker room and let the
sweeping waves come for me well yeah
that sounds good and promising and also
good okay water from control
so the water pump is going that means
the water level should be dropping and I
should be able to move forward now okay
all right okay okay here we go
still in the room 9 10 a music is a
little weird Oh what not what I was
expecting not at all what I was
expecting
okay move a little faster going sideways
actually weird this is so so weird so
weird weird weird all the staff is gone
only I remain for no purpose I remain
here resisting the call from behind the
sealed door but I will remain as long as
I can
don't open that door I opened it to get
in here I think pretty sure I pretty
sure I open that door there when you
were talking about
No
yes oh hi that's going hello hi are you
oh crap it's bad for me
I got start over the beginning don't I
son of a [ __ ] oh hi how you doing oh
crap dammit
okay also I didn't realize I can jump up
on the boxes I can kind of climb up okay
it's totally like the water bouncer from
amnesia by the by
okay okay crap crap crap crap crap crap
okay cylinder room 910 gotta go
turn
box tall [ __ ] [ __ ] should I just walk my
mic just fell and nailed me in the balls
dammit I don't like doing this again
I should just stayed on a box I would
have been what is this the hell is this
what is this this is new whoa okay
apparently I found the secret place all
right then I don't know if I found that
room before maybe I have maybe having
okay so here we go again here we go
again
stay away from her here we go here we go
Oh video video video video video ooh
there we go
fine
the durian
no nowhere I'm on
cause right here was right here go
that's how you do it that's how you
gonna do
these are just like the basically the
same oh I am going up
I am okay
okay so I finally am going up in room
number yeah I just have to worry about
this mermaid chasing after me
which isn't cool
I'm cool by the way what I would call
cool
I don't know in this in French hell
but hey it's fun while it lasts I guess
very stuff and go on this baloney
to make it past all the bowl
okay I can do without all the water down
to do without it
I can do without it okay I can
definitely do without it now hey man
also I forgot it's faster to run
sideways through the water I don't even
need to worry about my sprint meter I
just move Chris Kwazii I move super fast
this is gonna be my life now this is
gonna be my life
I do something else alright so um I do
is I want to cut this episode here sorry
I took so long to get through this but
thank you everybody someone for watching
click the annotation for our videos that
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye
magazine nuclear rod and get out of here
oh my god
it's 30 bucks Jim oh my god
yo-o-ow is the breathing uh-oh I didn't
know how is it